game show contestants have to overcome a
lot in order to emerge from the
experience unscathed there's money at
stake pressure to win and just the
general stress of being on television
for what's probably the first and only
time in their lives it's not surprising
in other words when the stress makes
them screw up big-time
thankfully the internet grants these
moments immortality and we found some of
the best ones the worst Wheel of Fortune
contestant ever Indiana University honor
student Julian batts also known as the
worst Wheel of Fortune contestant ever
put in an especially awful performance
on the show that found him offering not
one not two but three forehead slapping
answers first he flubbed the
pronunciation of Achilles mythological
hero a chalice fair enough let's just
assume he never studied Greek mythology
and he isn't a brad pitt fan next he
blew an incredibly easy chance to win a
car he shut off yeah the world's fastest
man yeah that's it
but his guess on this puzzle was this on
the spot die spin
this guy thinks dice spin is one word
and he also thinks you spin dice
needless to say it was not Indiana
University's finest moment in the
spotlight another wheel of misfortune
okay you've got three letters remaining
in this puzzle
you're probably gonna solve right well
that wasn't contestant KC's plan instead
she made an on-the-spot dye spin every
hardcore wheel watcher knows she's
playing with fire but she Luck's out
after guessing the G in nightclub she
gets to pick up the $10,000 but then
when most sane people would have solved
the puzzle which only had two letters
left KC goes and does this Oh
Kasey's playing the game show equivalent
of Russian roulette at this point the
wheel barely makes it one peg past
bankrupt this is complete insanity all
she has to do to get that money is say X
or V you know the only letters left in
the word exclusive a letter okay
no Casey just no romantic geometry
jeopardy is always leaned toward the
brain ear side of televised game shows
it takes itself seriously well at least
more seriously than some of the
competition fart in a bit that's why it
was so surprising when contestant Cara
had this response to the clue if Andy
yearns for Brenda and Brenda cares about
Charlene who pines for Andy the three of
them form one of these Cara what does a
threesome to be fair her answer isn't
necessarily wrong but it isn't
necessarily right either the answer of
course was love triangle host Alex
Trebek a seasoned pro went into the kill
Cara has obviously had much more
experience Trebek you old scoundrel
listening helps Family Feud contestant
Holly just wanted to win the faceoff to
give her family the chance to pass or
play so she didn't even let host Steve
Harvey finish the question name
something a woman does for her baby
yes change this diaper
bad move Holly she probably should have
let Steve finish reading his card name
something a woman does for her baby that
she also does for her hubby on the other
hand maybe she and her husband have an
understanding who are we to judge you do
you Holly some couples are truly made
for each other the newlywed game hangs
its entire premise on the uncomfortable
reality that couples may not know each
other as well as they think they do in
Gloria and Joe's case this couldn't be
further from the truth
when asked how many decades roll your
husband say his mother has lived Gloria
visibly realizes the trouble her husband
Joe would have with this answer and yet
she confidently states tan decade
the audience laughs and thinks this is
ridiculous but then Joe comes back out
and we see the Gloria knows her husband
better than he knows himself oh I don't
know what decade is what do you support
this I should be good at four years
decades you did ten decades tender
Joe hold on to Gloria and never let her
go you'll never find a woman who
understands and accepts you like she
does thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which gameshow
fails you think should have made the
list